i've changed not as much as bruce jenner
obviously now caitlyn jenner
of course what a year she's had she
became a role model for trans people
everywhere
showing great bravery in breaking down
barriers and destroying stereotypes
she didn't do a lot for women drivers
but
you can't have everything you are such
an incredible athlete people forget
just how fast you once ran from your
first family
to go be on a reality show
[Applause]
i just think it's so strange that we're
calling her a woman she's such a dummy
yeah he was a dumb guy he was a he was a
male kardashian
and then all of a sudden he's like
celebrated well the greatest woman of
all time a wonder woman of the year
i'm just having a hard time swallowing
all this and between me and this one
over here we can swallow just about
anything
oh god you're such an atoll a guy told
me that uh i don't know if you've heard
this
bruce jenner is gonna go back maybe to
being a man
that's an odd thing because i remember
him
of course as a woman
so it's hard for me to picture what he'd
even look like
as a man i remember because i'm from
canada so i remember he was in the 72
olympics
and he he won the he won the the
decathlon you know which is the the the
best athlete in the world
was a woman and we didn't know at the
time because he kept a secret
but i remember they put the gold medal
around as
[ __ ] big juicy tits
and that to me is when they should have
he should just go i'm a lady and then
that would have been good for the lgbt
the community you know the community i
know if you've been over
seeing him and [ __ ] but it's a nice
community
and it would have been good all the lgbt
i tried to be inclusive of all the
letters in the alphabet
but you know then he but he waited
that's the problem he waited till
65 that's when bruce jenner decided to
tell us he was a lady
now i don't know about you guys but to
me
is there really that much difference
between a 65 year old
at some point you got to realize
you're just some old thing nobody wants
to [ __ ]
that's what killed me when bruce became
caitlyn that was like a
national news story like at a ridiculous
level this guy
walked out a dude came back a woman
you're just supposed to be like oh yes
anyways caitlyn
uh god bless him god bless her sorry
they really freaked out about the
pronouns too yeah yeah you say god bless
him and they're like hey
[ __ ] bruce jenner is the only white man
to win a gold medal running against
black men this [ __ ] was a man
amongst men you beat a [ __ ] running you
a bad white one
he stuck his dick in the mama kardashian
that [ __ ] said [ __ ] it keep it
there
just give me your clothes
kylie jenner who has i believe fake
boobs fake ass
fake hips fake jaws big nose fake lips
everything
this girl fake puss if she's tucked we
don't even know if she's tucked
right right right fake puss maybe lips
this girl is technically more real
yeah not more girl but more real
than kylie 100 so have all these
girls in their plastic surgery the
hollywood plastic surgery aesthetic if
you will
have they opened the door to us
cracking open [ __ ] because they're
just as fake or just as real are women
meeting [ __ ] halfway and now it's
become so like
normalizing we're so used to body parts
not being real
that once we see a dude with some body
parts on our rail we're like well it's
no different than the last girl i dated
it's a problem
ladies you did it i'm just saying
brazilian trans lives matter
if you put that on don't it make sense
that the baddest [ __ ] trans would be
brazilian
now that make the most sense out of all
this
bro it's so true so this is the most
work he's ever been to
we really want to [ __ ] do right now
so i don't wanna [ __ ] a dude
i wanna [ __ ] damn dude
that single guy could get some [ __ ]
neck
that's a neck
[Music]
you